the death of an unarmed black man has
been incredibly difficult to prosecute a
police officer successfully we can never
be satisfied as long as the Negro is the
victim of the unspeakable horrors of
police brutality Jonathan Farrell was
unarmed he died just a month shy of his
25th birthday
now that officer Randall Carrick is
charged with voluntary manslaughter a
mistrial was declared in a case of a
white police officer who shot and killed
an unarmed black man there were protests
outside the court after the mistrial was
announced Friday a heart attack on
Thursday the father of six can be heard
on the tape saying repeatedly many
people simply cannot understand why the
grand jury did not indict when they
could actually see video of what went
down between that New York police
officer and Eric garner Michael Brown an
unarmed 18 year old was shot and killed
during a struggle with a Ferguson police
officer Darren Wilson will not be
indicted the feeling among many of these
people that black lives don't matter
not one reason that this grand jury
finds two indictment Chicago Police
Officer Jason van Dyke shot and killed
17 year-old laQuan McDonald for the
first time in 35 years a Chicago police
officer is charged with first-degree
murder found guilty of second degree
murder very unusual very important it is
goes to show you how serious that I am
about my life and all these other lies
that are out here that are scared of the
police an officer shot and killed 12
year-old Tamir rice on Sunday Tamir rice
was playing with a pellet gun when
officers arrived one of them opened
fired within two seconds grand jury
decided not to indict the two officers
who shot and killed 12 year old Samir
rice Cleveland's prosecutor calls it a
tragedy but not a crime doesn't even
warrant a trial that in my mind is
unacceptable think of the death of
Freddie gray all lives matters but you
got to think about who dying out here
prosecutors in Baltimore dropped all
remaining charges against three police
officers in the Freddie gray case Samuel
DuBose was shot in the head Sunday after
being pulled over for a missing license
plate officer Raymond tensing has now
been charged with murder and voluntary
manslaughter
now those charges have been dismissed we
will never get a conviction in this case
the death of Alton sterling
african-american man killed by police in
Louisiana the Louisiana Department of
Justice cannot proceed with a
prosecution all we want is the same
judgment if they put against us whenever
we go through certain trials in
tribulations volando Castile a
supervisor at a school cafeteria where
kids loved him police officer Geronimo
Llanes shot Castile to death while he
was in the car with his girlfriend and
her four-year-old daughter Jairus Valley
on edge was reasonable in his decision
to shoot and kill falando Castile during
a traffic stop last July just because he
was a police officer that makes it okay
I think the past two shootings londo
have really sparked something people
being murdered unjustly and not being
held accountable cops are getting paid
leave for killing people former fans
burning is number seven Jersey I hope
you didn't cut 40 year old terrance
Crutcher was killed on Friday when local
officers responded to a call of a
stalled vehicle in the middle of the
road 12 jurors found a TBD officer Betty
shall be not guilty of manslaughter in
the shooting of Terrence cruncher but
that for they're all the elements of
manslaughter was there the death of 22
year old stuff on Clark's Park
nationwide protests Clark was hit 20
times he was in his grandparents
backyard at the time
man but those poor gonna come behind him
police officers will not face charges
saying they did not break any laws when
they shot Stephane Clark and his
grandparents backyard in the same cop
who killed him is back on the streets
patrolling other communities were going
through other people's backyards not
easy with that anger over night over the
shooting death of 26 year old both in
Jean in his own apartment former Dallas
police officer Amber Geiger is waking up
this morning behind bars she was found
guilty yesterday of murdering her
neighbor in his own home Tatyana is her
name and everyone is seeing that name on
social media there she is she was up
playing video games with her nephew when
she was shot and killed by former Fort
Worth police officer Erin D the Fort
Worth police officer who shot at Tatyana
Jefferson in her own home has been
formally charged with mother
[Music]
[Laughter]
Brianna Taylor a woman was shot and
killed in her apartment
George Floyd died in police custody
after an officer pressed his knee in to
Floyd's neck said I can't breathe
yearly similar so we heard 2014 with
Eric garner and filed an amended
complaint the charges former Minneapolis
police officer Derek Chavez with murder
in the second degree
Jewish boys whose killing by u.s. police
triggered anti-racism protests right
around local protests and international
support and ignites
protesters marched once again in cities
worldwide demanding police departments
change their tactics
you're bored
you